as a band geek i was i was getting
classically trained in the daytime
and taught by brand newbie and chuck d
at night that's kind of the mix i come
from in the late late 80s early 90s 14
15 years old and i'm watching
do the right thing in
school days and a different world and
i'm just
it was the best time to be a black
teenager i believe i agree i agree and
just like you
hip-hop hip-hop encouraged me to learn
more about myself absolutely because
there are certain things
to be honest with you
i wasn't learning in the church about my
history and i wasn't learning in school
about my history at least certain
artists told me to go pick up a book and
open it and learn more about where you
come from from a production standpoint
being a producer
walking into the studio
and trying to create something special
what is the process like for you
and what has been the process for some
of the greats that you have worked on to
to capture history i believe
you know i come from a long line of
producers who sample and sometimes you
know music america looks at sampling as
quote unquote stealing right so to speak
right right um i had a chance to spend a
couple of years at harvard university um
learning under dr marcy morgan and dr
henry louis grace jr
and i had to present in front of henry
lewis gates a colloquium about sampling
right
you're right pressure pressure under
pressure
but there's one thing he taught me at
the end of my colloquium he said
sampling is repetition with the
difference
pretty much
um
to
take something old make something new
and expose it to a new generation it's
happened before but it's it's it's about
being able to tell our story through the
music
we always pass messages that way we've
been passing messages like this since we
got here yeah and we have a special way
of doing it and a lot of hip-hop records
taught me about the 70s and about music
that sometimes my parents didn't
sometimes my aunt and uncles did it you
know we talk about
the evolution of hip-hop
i put an emphasis on lyrical content of
course i grew up
with the radio right
as soon as i hear something i'm stopping
i'm hitting the rewind right got to get
to the right part right make sure i
heard it right so i can memorize it
right
i even have to double cassette where i
can record at the same time and spit
over it you know i thought i was going
to be a rapper until i started catching
football um
i feel like there is a duality in
hip-hop
right
you can have the ratchet and the ratchet
is necessary absolutely but
you also have the righteous right and i
think the righteous
is like the guiding light for hip-hop
[Music]
what do you lean towards
i mean
first of me being producer i leaning
towards the beats
yeah i want to see what the producer is
doing
and
i think just like movies you have
comedies you have dramas you have
rom-coms you have
you know horror films yeah hip-hop is
the same way we have the right to have
that range so i've i've grown to
understand that
the problem is
america doesn't like to hear about that
ugly side of the story
they want to hear about this particular
side
but all of the ones that the older
generation may say oh they're not
talking about anything
they're telling their story they're
talking about something they're talking
about something and is there
connectivity in that of course it is
but they have a right to tell their
story yeah and and then at the same time
we don't know what kind of
lifestyle changes is being made for them
while they're telling that story right
we don't know how much of how much
generational wealth they're creating for
themselves yeah
that's what i i kind of started to learn
they have a right to do it do well
listen to it all the time i might not
right will i down the young man or woman
for doing it no not anymore yeah not at
all you know their music is a direct
reflection of what they're going through
absolutely and if you look at some of
your favorite artists
earlier works you'll realize that they
also evolved right jay-z is an example i
oftentimes point to listen to what he
was talking about when he first got in
the game and then at some point he was
like no rims on the car no buttons up i
mean take the jersey's office put the
button ups on i need to start investing
in art and what have we started doing as
black people we're like you know what i
think i might buy me a picasso because
jay said it
i'm not a businessman i'm a business
business man exactly
i said that hip-hop is like heir to me
i need it
so
i'll start the sentence and i'll let you
finish it
hip-hop is me